new at noon the centers for disease
control is extending the federal
eviction moratorium through june 30th
it was supposed to expire on wednesday
our bianca holman is live this afternoon
to explain how this will affect
local renters and landlords bianca
good afternoon john well those who are
facing addictions they can breathe a
little bit easier today
the federal eviction moratorium was
extended just two days before it was to
expire
now of course the pandemic has forced
people out of work it also has forced
people to remain home
and that social distancing again it
helps decrease the spread of covet 19
and also as a key step
to keeping people out of shelters we
spoke with the executive director of
nevada state apartment association she
tells us last summer more than 50
percent of their landlords reported
renters using assistance that number is
down to around 15 percent now
but many people are still in need she
also says it's crucial for renters to
make a plan now
with their landlord it is
critical right now that people that are
able to make rent payments make those
payments in order to be able to maintain
that roof over their head
because landlords are in equal dire
straits and many times especially the
smaller ones
when it comes to making their landlord i
mean their mortgage payments
and though there is a moratorium all
background must be paid this does make
it challenging for smaller landlords
so foreclosure could be inevitable for
some this summer
and also there are grants available for
small business owners but those are
going fast
and if you're potentially facing
eviction the cares act does have some
money available for those renters and
even landlords
if you're in need of help all you need
to do is call 2-1-1 reporting live
bianca holman 8 news now